I'm asking, do you have any empathy
with the Palestinian position?
I have zero empathy
to people the time after time refuse to.
To recognize
the right of the Jewish state to their homeland.
Jewish people in their homeland.
I have zero sympathy
because I want to.
To live in a world where we can live together.
How can they deny?
But they deny.
You have no
zero empathy in your own words
with those people?
No, it's not what I said.
I said I have zero sympathy to the fact
that they lost their land.
They didn't lost their land.
They committed the crime of attacking the small.
The small state of Israel were
after the UN decision.
So there is no. That.
The truth is
there is no empathy.
I have empathy for the tragedy of the leadership.
Yes, I have empathy that they are under
the tragedy of their leadership.
This is a very hopeless conversation
then, isn't it?
No, it's not.
Because I think what's really hopeless is to build
imaginary solutions.
What's really hopeless
is to think that a terror organization
is something that will never hurt you.
I think that the imaginary and illusionary discourse
that many people have need to be.